I am finishing up the album but we're
also trying to figure out a fun way to
to take our time there's no date there's
no idea for it but I have a lot of music
that I've collectively put away Selena
Gomez confirming a third studio album is
in the works she video chatted with
beats one hosts Zane Lowe on Thursday
and also debuted her new song
[Applause]
[Music]
it's called back to you and as part of
the 13 reasons why season 2 soundtrack I
know I go back to you
Selena co-wrote it and were definitely
picking up on some potential Justin
Bieber references miss appointment I and
everybody knows we got unfinished
business the bear has been on and off
for years they got back together last
fall but recently called it quits again
a source tells ET quote they both know
that right now Selena doesn't have it in
her to be in a serious relationship
especially one that causes stress and
drama in her life it's been a
rollercoaster year for Selena after
taking a break from the spotlight she
also underwent a kidney transplant last
year I've been very aware of my platform
and I don't try to hide any part of
flaws that are in me I feel the best I
felt just for now I'm hoping to keep
eating it you know but I'm super happy I
love people I take really good care of
myself and yes just sometimes it's hard
you know you'll never really get over
stuff you gotta just have to get better
and better and work on it it's one step
at a time
you